[MUSIC]
These buildings were never
meant to be lived in.
These streets were
never meant for traffic.
These walls were never
meant for family photos.
This is an abandoned town that
was built to be abandoned,
except for a few days every year
when it's a literal war zone.
[SPEAKING OVER RADIO]
[GUNSHOTS]
This is Fort Ord, a
former US military base,
once inhabited by
soldiers, civilians,
and even German
prisoners of war.
It's now a place of business,
education, and adventure.
But past the hiking
trails and the fences,
beyond the accessible
and familiar,
is this place, Impossible City.
This cement block
city sits alone
in its namesake,
Impossible Canyon.
It was built in 1984,
but it feels much older,
as if it were once a
real community that
was abandoned for some reason,
leaving only these gray,
ghost-like buildings.
Abandoned places
like these often
make us daydream of what
once could have been
or what once was.
The schoolhouse where the
local children learned,
the office building where
their parents worked,
the town square where
the community gathered
to celebrate this small city.
But it's a history
that never existed.
The realness of
Impossible City is it
it's unfortunate necessity,
built as a reaction
to the ever-changing
face of war,
one that has moved out of
the jungle and the desert
and into urban environments.
Impossible City is an active
urban military training
zone, a real life simulation to
prepare for real life battles.
Its generic, gray
facades are designed
not to look like any one
city, but instead to be
a stand-in for all cities.
Training men and women on
how to approach sniper fire
in the Middle East, or how to
sweep an apartment building
in middle America.
This is where troops
trained before they
were deployed to Panama
to capture dictator Manuel
Noriega.
Today it remains quiet.
Today it is a peaceful city.
Silence has replaced gunfire,
shadows have replaced soldiers,
and the boot marks in the dirt
have blown away in the wind.
Impossible City is a town
where no one has ever lived,
and a war zone where
no one has ever died.
If you'd like to watch another
episode of Abandonment Issues,
click here now to visit
a deserted rail yard.
These walls were put
up over 100 years ago
on landfill made partially
from the debris of the 1906
earthquake that devastated
much of the Bay Area.
And don't forget to subscribe.
Thank you for watching.